[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد
67 يوما من بدء هجماته المكثفه على مدينه
خان يونس في قطاع غزه وبعد
122 يوما من حربه على غزه التي فاق عدد
ضحاياها 100 ال بين شهيد وشريح ومف
لا يزال الجيش الاسرائيلي يواجه مقاومه
شرسه من مقاتل كتائب القسام وبقيه فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الاخرى حصلت الجزيره
على تسجيل المصور يظهر جانبا منها ويوضح
استهداف القسام اليات الاحتلال المتوغلة
هذا الامر من دون ان توضح اسباب عجزها عن
تحقيقه في اكثر من تسعه اسابيع مضى وفي
غمره المتاعب التي يواجهها بسبب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في خان يونس شرع الاحتلال في
تنفيذ احزمه ناريه في المنطقه الفاصله بين
خان يونس ورفح تمهيدا فيما يبدو لما يقول
انها عمليه عسكريه بريه في مدينه رفح
المكتظه بالنازحين اكدت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان شنها سيترافع مع عمليات
لتهجير هؤلاء النازحين شمالا وان التنسيق
جار بين تل ابيب والجانب المصري بشان
تنفيذها للعمليه العسكريه وفق الهيئه
الاعلان الاسرائيلي عن عمليه في رفح ترافق
مع تجديد نتنياهو تعهده باطلاق سراح
الرهائن في غزه من خلال ما سماه نصرا
مطلقا يقضي تماما على حركه حماس في قطاع
غزه وهو تعهد يتزامن مع نقل اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن كبار قاده الجيش القول ان
القضاء على قدرات حماس الصاروخيه فقط
يتطلب ما بين عام الى عامين تقديراتهم
تشير الى ان حماس لا تزال تحتفظ بالف
صاروخ منصوبه على منصات اطلاقها في مواقع
تحت الارض تعجز القوات الاسرائيليه عن
الوصول
اليها نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من الناصره ايهاب
جبارين الكاتب المخ في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن نيويورك داليا فهمي استاذه العلوم
السياسيه في جماعه لونغ ايلاند اهلا بهم
جميعا لواء فاز دويري اليوم
لدينا مفارقه من من ناحيه الصور التي حصلت
عليها الجزيره وتم بثها عن اعمال للمقاومه
في غرب خان يونس ومن ناحيه اخرى قبل قليل
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن ان كتيبه
خان يونس في حماس على وشك الانهيار وان
المعركه تقريبا شبه حسمت كيف نفسر هذه
المفارقه لا هناك يعني اي لا يوجد انسجام
ما بين
ال القولين لانه اذا اذا استندنا الى
تصريحاته عن شمال غزه مدينه غزه القاطع
الشمالي تحدث قبل اكثر من اسبوعين بانه تم
تفكيك تنظي تنظيم كتائب مدينه غزه وتم
تدمير 700 منصه اطلاق صواريخ
وتم قتل 9000 من اصل 12000 تحدث بذلك
وتبين لاحقا ان
معلوماته ان المعلومات التي تقدم بها
خاطئه وغير منطقيه ولا تنسجم لانه الان
الان الان القتال على اشده في منطقه جنوب
غرب مدينه غزه في تل الهواء والشيخ عجلين
والرمال الجنوبي وبالتالي كما تحدث عن
القاطع الشمالي يتحدث الان الفيديو اللي
ظهر في هذا اليوم كان تقريبا في حوالي خمس
لقطات جميعها كل كل لقطه منها تعبر عن شيء
القتال من مسافه الصفر استخدام الحشوات
استخدام الياسين اذا دعني اقول كلامه
يتناقض مع الواقع الميداني بصوره قاطعه
نعم في
الاثناء سيد ايهاب جبارين اليوم هذه
اللهجه الواثقه التي تحدث بها جلنت
سبق ان تحدث قبل ثلاثه ايام
فقط قال تم تفكيك قوه حماس وهذا ما سيحدث
ايضا في رفح وقبله بيوم واحد فقط اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي تقول
بان المعركه
تقريبا الوضع يعني شبه انتهى في في خان
يونس لماذا تراه يؤكد على ذلك في حين ان
لم نرى شيئا ويقولون انهم يحتاجون الى
اسبوع
اضافي نعم تحياتي استاذ محمد وا مساء
الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام بطبيعه الحال هذا
هذه اللهجه وهذه النبره هي التي كانت
وسيطرت على الاجواء منذ الاسبوع الاول
لهذه لهذا العدوان ولهذه الحرب عندما
توغلت وارادت ان تتوغل اسرائيل في مستشفى
الشفاء بعدما خرجت من ذلك كانت تحاول ان
تبحث عن صوره نصر معينه ب بهيئه انجازات
معينه تستطيع تسويقها الى داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي وهنا ربما تجدر الاشاره انه
على مدار 122 يوما الشارع الاسرائيلي
يترقب في صبيحه كل يوم وسائل اعلامه
والصحف بانتظار صوره النصر هذه ال يعني
هنالك عدسه مكبره موجهه نحو هذه الحكومه
من كل فئات المجتمع الاسرائيلي من هم
متواجدون عن يمين هذه الحكومه ومن هم
متواجدون عن يسارها بطبيعه الحال من هم
متواجدون عن يسارها يترقبون للانتقاد
للانتقاد منها في كل لحظه ومن هم موجودون
عن يمينها يريدون تلك اللهفه لهذه الصوره
التي تدعم حقهم بكل ما يقوم تقوم به
حكومتهم في وفق وجهه نظرهم تحديدا في
الميدان في هذه الفتره وبالتالي هذه
النبره وهذه اللهجه التي يتغنى بها جلنت
على مدار كل هذه الفتره وعلى مدار كل ال
122 يوم بطبيعه الحال لم يستطيع ان يصدر
ولو لمره واحده صوره حقيقيه عدا ربما هنا
بعض الانفاق هنا وهناك ارقام وهي نقطه
مهمه جدا عندما تصدر اسرائيل الارقام يجب
ان نتذكر انها هي الوحيده التي تملك ايه
حقيقه هذه الارقام او هي تؤمن بانها هي
الوحيده التي تؤمن تصدر حقيقه هذه الارقام
وبالتالي لا يوجد ايه دلائل مصداقيه حتى
على هذه الارقام هذا هو الواقع الذي تحاول
ان تتصدر منه وتخرج ايه من ازمتها
الداخليه تحديدا في ظل كل ما تواجهه الان
من الصفقه وعدمها في داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي معركه خانيونس سيده داليا فهمي
وصفها رئيس الرئيس السابق ل شعبه العمليات
في الجيش والقائد السابق لفرقه غزه اللواء
اسرائيل زيف ماذا قال عنها قال هي المعركه
الاهم والاكثر صعوبه وتعقيدا والاهداف
التاليه مقارنه بها تعتبر ثانويه برايك
كيف كيف تبدو هذه المعركه معركه خان يونس
في سياق كل ما يجري في قطاع غزه سياسيا
ربما اكثر منها
عسكريا خانيونس هي من بين المدن الاكبر في
جنوب قطاع غزه وخانيونس هي المكان الذي
فيه معقل اساسي للمقاومه جالنز قال يوم
الخميس الماضي ان المعركه قد انتصرت فيها
اسرائيل واليوم يتحدث عن اسبوع اضافي
وبالتالي النظره هي ان العمليه لم تشارف
على النهايه وفي حقيقه الامر اذا ما عاينا
الاوضاع السياسيه الداخليه في اسرائيل منذ
السابع من اكتوبر هناك نظره عامه ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار الامن ولا ليس باستطاعتها ان
تحمي المواطنين الاسرائيليين في الجنوب لم
تتمكن الحكومه من منع الهجمات الاساسيه
ولم تتمكن كذلك الحكومه من القضاء على
حماس في قطاع غزه وبالتالي مؤشر النجاح
كان خان يونس وهذا المؤشر ينتقل الان الى
رفح وبالتالي عدم قدره اسرائيل على
الاعلان عن انتصار واضح والتحدث بقصص
متغيره بشكل سريع يؤدي الى النظره بان
الشعب الاسرائيلي غير راض بشكل متزايد
ازاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه والقوات عسكريه
الاسرائيليه بالنسبه الى خانيونس
والانتقال الى رفح نحن نعرف
ان رفح عباره عن 65 م مربع هي مسافه صغيره
او مساحه صغيره جدا وعدد كبير من النازحين
اجبروا على الهرب الى هناك وفي الاشهر
الماضيه كان هناك انذارات متكرره بعمليات
قصف الان الانذارات تاتي في غدون فتره
قصيره وما من مكان للهروب اليه ما شاهدناه
يوم امس واليوم وقتل الناس في رفح يؤشر
ذلك الى ان الفرصه تضيق بالنسبه الى
الاستراتيجيه المعتمده من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيل في غزه ويطرح السؤال حول ماهيه
هذا الانتصار ومتى سوف يحصل وما هي
الاستراتيجيه للحكومه الاسرائيليه وكيف
سيتفاعل المجتمع الاسرائيلي اذا ااء ذلك
وبالتالي هناك ناس عالقون بين المطرقه
والسندان على ذكر رفح تحديدا اللواء فايز
الدويري يعني كيف لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان يتحدث من الان ويروج لمعركه
في رفح وهو لم يحسم بعد لا المعركه في خان
يونس ولا المعركه حتى في شمال القطاع بشكل
كامل يا سيدي حتى هذه اللحظه بعد 122 يوم
لم يستطع ان يقدم انجازا عسكريا واحدا
ولكن تصريحاته سقف دائما عالي دائما يتحدث
عن تحقيق الاهداف دائما يتحدث عن القضاء
عن حماس دائما ولكن الواقع يقول عكس ذلك
رفح يبقى الوضع له خصوصيه الان رفح هناك
حدود مشتركه مع جمهوريه مصر العربيه مع
مصر ما هو موقف مصر يعني الحديث كثر
الحديث عن التنسيق ما بين الجانبين من اجل
معركه رفح ولكن هذا التنسيق لم يظهر
للعيان والجانب المصري لا يزال يرفض ذلك
الان يوجد مليون و300 ال في في شريط
فيلادلفيا كم عرض شريط فيلادلفيا متوسطه
500 متر وطوله 14 كيلو 300 متر ا اي في
مليون ف3 اين سيذهبوا الان اذا اذا
حتى اداره المعركه حتى هذه اللحظه لا
يستطيعوا ان ان ان يديروا المعركه بطريقه
على الاقل تكون مقبوله لحلفاء هم
الامريكيين و وهي وهي راس الحربه في
الهجوم الان عندما نتحدث عن خان يونس هو
يقول اسبوع اتحداه ان يكون ذلك كلامه دقيق
لا خانيونس يوجد فيها اقوى لواء ويوجد
فيها اشرس الكتائب من الفصال الاخرى منطقه
شرق طريق شارع صلاح الدين حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يستطع ان يحقق بها اي انجاز وهي ثلاث
اضعاف مساحه مدينه غزه مدينه خان يونس
عفوا نعم بالنسبه ل اللي رفح سيد ايهاب
جبارين في البدايه كانت هناك تصريحات
اسرائيليه منذ الثام عشر من يناير هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه تقول العمليه قد لا تتم
ايه قريبا ايضا جيروزالم بوست قالت في ال3
من يناير بانه لا توجد حاليا خطط فوريه
للدخول الى رفح او السيطره على معبر
فيلادلفيا ولكن مع ذلك نجد الان وتيره
الحديث عن رفح تزداد قوه مع ان ما يجري في
خان يونس لا ينب بان الامور حسمت كيف تبدو
الصوره
هناك
ن نعم بطبيعه الحال يعني هذا ربما كان
كذلك المشهد منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الحرب
في الصوره لم تحسم في داخل مستشفى الشفاء
ولا في شمالي القطاع وكان الحديث والاعين
تصوب نحو جنوبي وادي غزه ما بعد ذلك ذلك
الامر عندما دخلت الى المنطقه الوسطى بدات
تتحدث عن المنطقه الجنوبيه هو مشهد
كلاسيكي بات واضحا ان اسرائيل لا يوجد
لديها اي يعني او خطتها بشكل اضاق هي جزء
من مشهد الارباك المتواجد في داخل
الكابينت الذي يبحث عن صوره نصر ايا كانت
وربما مازال يبحث عن عن معجزه عيد الانوار
الذي مضى في شهر ديسمبر ما زالت تبحث عن
هذه المنجزه التي قد تنقذ بنيامين نتنياهو
تنقذ المستوى العسكري الكل يريد صوره
انقاذ يسوقها الى داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي
هذا في هذا المشهد ولكن هنالك ربما كذلك
امر اخر يتم استنباطه من كل ما تقوم به
اسرائيل في داخل القطاع على ما يبدو انها
تفتح كل الدفاتر القديمه وتبحث عن كل
الانجازات التي لم تنجزها منذ ان كانت في
داخل القطاع منذ ما قبل حتى عام 2006
وتبحث عن كيفيه اغلاق كل الدوائر المفتوحه
رفح وفيلادلفيا على تحديدا في عام 2004
كان هنالك عمليه قامت بها في داخل رفح
حاولت فيها منع الانفاق انذاك رغم انها
كانت تسيطر على محور فيلا دلفي حتى عام
2005 وعلى ما يبدو انها تحاول اغلاق كل
هذه الدوائر المفتوحه باعاده السيطره على
رفح واعاده السيطره وصولا وهو ربما ال
المحور الاهم محور فيلا دلفي كهدف من بين
كل الاهداف التي تريدها لضمه الى ما تسميه
في هذه المرحله الشريط العازل او او
المنطقه الامنه نعم سيده دال يا فهمي
الحديث
عن
رفح يستلزم
بالضروره التنسيق مع مصر كما تذكر اسرائيل
اكثر من مره وهناك حديث عن ان مدير الشباك
زار القاهره وفق ما ذكرته اكسيوس عن
مسؤولين اسرائيليين للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
تحديدا هل تعتقدين بان مصر قد تتجاوب مع
هذه الحسابات
الاسرائيليه الوضع بالنسبه الى العلاقه مع
مصر هو معقد للغايه من جهه مصر حصلت على
ضمانات من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بانهم
لن يشاركون في لن يشاركوا في هذه الهجره
الجماعيه من فلسطين الى مصر هذا النزوح من
غزه الى مصر
من ناحيه
اخرى في مصر نحن نعرف وفقا
لتقارير
الاخيره نرى ان المساعدات
الانسانيه تخضع ل 5000 دولار امريكي
للشاحن لكي تدخل الى قطاع غزه والناس
الذين يهربون من القطاع يدفعون حوالي
7500 دولار لمغادره البلاد كرشاوي
وبالتالي الوضع بالنسبه الى الامن على
الحدود وبالنسبه الى قطاع غزه وسكان قطاع
غزه وجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
هو وضع في غايه الصعوبه هناك ضمانات قدمت
من قبل الرئيس بايدن والسيد بلينكن بان
مصر لن تشارك في النزوح الجماعي من غزه
الى مصر وبالتالي نرى ايضا ان مصر عالقه
بين المطرقه والسندان وهناك ايضا جزء
مرتبط
بالمفاوضات التي تجري برعايه قطريه ولكن
بالنسبه الى الشعب المصري هناك مشكله
داخليه من حيث التضخم وقد ينظر الى
الحكومه على انها تؤذي الاقتصاد من خلال
السماح بهجره جماعيه من فلسطين وبالتالي
هناك مظاهرات كبيره داعمه للشعب الفلسطيني
في مصر ولكن القياده يجب ان تنقل هذه
النبره وبالتالي هناك علاقه معقده بالنسبه
الى الاجهزه الامنيه والرشاوى وكل ذلك ادى
الى نظره ان مصر لا تلعب ورقه نظيفه اذا
اذا ما صح القول
وفقط ما يكفي من مساعدات يدخل الى قطاع
غزه عبر الحدود مع مصر لتغطيه 10% من
الاحتياجات في قطاع غزه وبالتالي العلاقه
بين مصر واسرائيل والولايات المتحده ا
هناك نظره معقده وغير واضحه و مبهمه وهذا
تعقيد تحديدا اللواء فايز الدويري وال في
المشهد الاسرائيلي المصري حول هذه النقطه
لتاكيد ذلك اسوشيتد بريس ذكرت في ال 26 من
يناير بان مصر ابلغت اسرائيل
انه قبل شن اي هجوم على رفح يجب عليها
السماح للفلسطينيين بالعوده الى شمال غزه
في حين ان مراسل اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول بان العوده الى شمال غزه يتطلب قرار
سياسي هذا الامر ليس محسوما ان يعودوا الى
شمال غزه او ان يعودوا الى خان يونس من
رفح ان يعودوا الى خان يونس بعد حسم
المعركه في خان يونس لكن لا المعركه حسمت
ولا القرار السياسي في شمال
غزه متخذ اذا كيف يجري التصرف يا سيدي حتى
هذه اللحظه يعني اولا لا يوجد تصريحات
واضحه جازمه من الجانب الم المصري هناك
ضبابيه في المشهد هناك انت ذكرت زياره
مدير الشيم بيتوا للاسف للاسف الموقف
المصري غير
واضح والنقطه
الاخرى يعني على ماذا يفاوض يفاوض على قتل
ابناء غزه هل يعني هل تهجيرهم الى الشمال
تهجيرهم الى الشمال القياده السياسيه غير
موافقه ذهابهم الى خ بدل ان يكون موقف
عروبي
يمثل حقيقه مصر التاريخيه يعني للاسف
مواقف الدول العربيه جميعها يعني ليس فقط
مصر الجميع متخاذل و يعني لا اود ان اقول
متامر على الاقل متخاذل لانه لو كان هناك
موقف عربي واضح لما جرى ما جرى في في غزه
وبالتالي الان هناك معظم سكان غزه الان
موجودين في شريط ضيق وبالتالي اين يذهب
ممنوع يدخل الى سيناء والغزي اصلا لا يرغب
في الذهاب الى سيناء يرغب في البقاء في وط
في وطنه لكن المعبر الم ي تتهم اسرائيل
مصر في محكمه لاهاي انها هي المسؤوله عن
اغلاق المعبر بينما لا يدخل اي شيء الا
بدفع ضريبي للجانب المصري وبموافقته
الاسرائيلي الرئيس المصري اشار قبل يومين
بان المعبر مفتوح 24 ساعه على 24 ساعه من
الجانب المصري ولكن التعقيدات من الجانب
الاسرائيلي على الاقل هذه وجهه النظر
المصريه كما تقول في في جمله واحده في عام
21 2021 ل عندما كان الرئ اسف
2014 الم يفتح رغم انف اسرائيل الم يرسل
رئيس الوزراء والكبت الوزاري المصري الى
داخل الى داخل
غزه ما هو
الفرق ان يقول ان اسرائيل تتحكم اين
السياده المصريه نقطه اخر السطر نعم
بالنسبه لموضوع رفح تحديدا سيد ايهاب
جبارين الجارديان نقلت عن مسؤول رفيع
المستوى في الامم المتحده يقول مدينه رفح
هي اخر مكان متبق يتمتع باي نظام مدني
حقيقي بسبب وجود سلطه حماس المحليه هناك
بمعنى ان تقريبا اذا وصلنا الى الى رفح هو
انهيار كامل في كل ما يتعلق بوجود سلطه
تدير الشؤون المدنيه على الاقل بالحد
الادنى هل هل تعتقد بان الامور يمكن ان
تصل الى هذا الحد و تصبح قطاع غزه مدمر
بالكامل ليس فقط بالمعنى العسكري وانما
ايضا بالمعنى
المدني يعني ربما في هذا المنظار يمكن
القول ما اشار اليه احد رؤساء الشين بيت
السابقون في من من سنوات ال 90 لا اذكر
اسمه بالتحديد و ولكن انه قال ان المعركه
حسمت الاهداف تقريبا اسرائيل لم ت تستطيع
ان تحدد كل الاهداف التي ارادتها لكن كل
القضيه لاداره ال القطاع ويعني ما ابقت
عليه اسرائيل في نهايه المطاف هو تقريبا 2
مليون مدني بدون ايه اداره باي شكل من
الاشكال و وبدون ايه يعني استطاعه اعطائهم
ايه حقوق مدنيه بسيطه ومبسطه بدون اي شكل
من الاشكال وبالتالي كل ما استطاعت
اسرائيل ان تقدمه هو صوره انتقاميه ليس
الا لكن حماس لم يتم الاطاحه بها بكل معنى
الكلمه طبعا لم يتم اخراج الاسرى وكذلك لم
يتم اعاده استتباب الامن في مناطق الغلاف
فبالتالي هذه هي القضيه القضيه ان اسرائيل
خاضت هذه المعركه على الاقل من وجهه نظر
واحده هي
وجهه مسح وجه المعمار المدني او كل الاسس
المدنيه المتواجده في داخل القطاع هذا ما
يستطيع استنباطه اصلا كل الناظر الى خريطه
القطاع وكيفيه استهداف كل المباني كل
العمران كل البنيه التحتيه يعني عد عن ايه
ايه تدمير ال القاعده الشعبيه لحماس
وبالتالي محاوله تدمير قاعدتها المدنيه
بالتالي ب وتوافقا مع ذلك لم يتم اي انجاز
عسكري تستطيع اسرائيل ان تتفاخر به امام
ايه شارعها الاسرائيلي بدون ما ادنى شك
وبالتالي نعم يعني يمكن القول حتى ان
اسرائيل تدرك كان هذا هو الامر الوحيد
الذي ابقت عليه وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا لان في
نهايه المطاف على الاقل وفق المردود
السياسي وان لم يكن هنالك اي مردود سياسي
متوافق عليه في الاطياف الاسرائيليه
المختلفه ولكن ما بين من يريد اعاده
الاستيطان بشكل كامل واعاده الحكم العسكري
ومن بين من يريد الا يكون هنالك ايه
امكانيه لاقامه دوله فلسطينيه مثل هذا
السيناريو هو الامثل بالنسبه لكليهما ال
المشكله الان سيده داليه فهمي هو ان ما
يجري الان يجري في وقت دقيق جدا والكل
ينتظر رد حركه حماس وبقيه فصائل المقاومه
على صفقه تبادل الاسرى
والهدنه وغير ذلك من من المسائل وا الحديث
عن هذه الصفقه لا يمكن ان تتم الا اذا
انتهى الامر في خان يونس وا ربما اتضحت
الصوره فيما يتعلق برفح وكلاهما غير واضح
هل يمكن لهذه الصفقه ان تمر في اجواء
عسكريه وسياسيه من هذا
القبيل اليوم ما استمعنا اليه من القياده
على مستوى الامم المتحده بسبب التكاليف
المرتفعه على المستوى الانساني في خانيونس
الناس يغادرون خان يونس الى رفح بشكل
متزايد وهناك تنسيق للعوده الى الشمال
نعرف ان س % من كل المباني دمرت في الشمال
و90 بال من المنازل دمرت اين سوف يذهب
الناس وبالتالي هناك شروط يجب ان تنفذ في
الميدان بالنسبه الى الشروط الامنيه
والسلامه والممر الامن قبل الحديث عن هدنه
او عن وقف لاطلاق النار لذلك بالحديث عن
هذا الموضوع بين قطر واسرائيل وحماس طبعا
هناك امور عالقه بالنسبه الى
الوضع هل نتحدث عن هدنه هل نتحدث عن وقف
لاطلاق النار وقف طويل الامد لاطلاق النار
وبعد ذلك ما هو شكل الاداره في قطاع غزه
على سبيل المثال عندما نتحدث عن قياده
فلسطينيه اسرائيل تتحدث عن اداره
اسرائيليه للقطاع وبالتالي هناك شروط
متعدده عالقه او ظروف عالقه يجب ال معرفه
ما هي حقيقه الموضوع وطبعا هناك اراء
مختلفه بين اليمين واليسار والوسط في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واخيرا هناك ايضا
الحديث حول الاسرى وايضا الرهائن
الاسرى فلسطينيين من الاطفال كذلك
وبالتالي هناك اسئله متعدده تبقى من دون
اجابه بالنسبه الى اتفاق وقف الاطلاق
النار ما يزيد الامر تعقيدا اللواء فايز
الدويري انه بعد قرار محكمه العدل الدوليه
في لهاي لا المساعدات
ازدادت بل هناك استهداف للاونروا ولا حده
المعارك قلت اعداد الشهداء والجرحى في
ازدياد والان هناك خوف مما يمكن ان يحدث
في رفح هنا اشير فقط لما قاله بوب كيتشن
وهو نائب رئيس لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
لحالات الطوار لواشنطن بوست قال اذا وصلت
المعارك الى رفح سنشهد اعداد من القتلى
ربما غير مسبوق اذا نحن في في وضع نسير
فيه نحو الاسود يعني الان المسير نحو
الكارثه اذا اذا نفذت العمليه
العسكريه اولا لننظر الى الجغرافيا لننظر
الى الجغرافيا والى هذا الشريط الضيق
وبالتالي لا يوجد اصلا مجال لاداره معركه
بصوره ناجحه دون دون مجازر ترتكب وبالتالي
يجب
على الموقف الدولي الامم المتحده و
الداعمه لاسرائيل والدول العربيه يجب ان
يكون لديها موقف واضح لكن اسرائيل تعتبر
نفسها فوق القانون وفوق اطار المحاسبه مع
انها
ملزمه بمحكمه العدل ان تقدم تقرير خلال
شهر خلال
شهر سيدي هل نعيش في ظل دوله
القانون والا في ظل قانون القوه العالم
يعيش في في بحكم شريعه الغاب قانون القوه
وليس قوه القانون شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء
فاز دويري شكرا لك سيده داليا فهمي وشكرا
لك سيد ايهاب جبري بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله
الثامنه والصف بتوقيت مكه المكرمه